terrorism is not acceptable hooliganism
is not acceptable extortion is not
acceptable these are some of the slogans
protesters are chanting after a rising
violence in Pakistan's border region
with Afghanistan particularly in Swat
our children are not free to go to the
schools though to to Tech education our
elders are afraid of to go to mosque
because there is a fear of unknown in
the area have been created intentionally
these Elders were killed in a bomb
attack in lashkar last month tariki
Taliban or TTP is said to be responsible
the group controlled SWAT between 2007
and 2010 until it was crushed in a
military operation but since the Taliban
came to power in neighboring Afghanistan
Fighters have reappeared in swat and
other border areas in Pakistan
protesters are demanding government
intervention to prevent the TTP from
regaining a Stranglehold over the region
the government is either sleeping or
they have intentionally allowed the
terrorists to cross over the border into
Pakistan to create this chaos but this
time we are not going to take the brunt
and won't allow our easy house to fall
into the terrorist hands we'll stand and
fight this till the last drop of our
blood to save our areas
the government says although recent
talks with the TTP bore no concrete
results it will pursue peaceful means to
end the chaos protesters say they're
ready to march on Islamabad unless the
outlawed group is reined in